hi everyone we just wanted to jump on
here and give a quick special thank you
to our patreon thank you so much if it
weren't for y'all we wouldn't be able to
be putting episode 5 & 6 together we had
it all films but we went over-budget so
post-production we had to get the money
somewhere else Thank You patreon members
thank you so much specifically gonna
thank you in the credits right after
this by name also we're done with the
cabin the first cabin it's done with the
hexagon cabin on to the next well yes we
are trying to get the plans for the
caretaker house the main house we'll try
to get that passed through the county
meanwhile we're working on the property
trying to get things together
all them torn down dilapidated my
favorite words all the dilapidated
cabins were salvaging everything we can
and getting ready to go for number two
yes so hopefully see you for the next
thank you so much thank you so much for
making that that possible we wouldn't be
able to document it the way we wanted to
if it weren't for you so we appreciate
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you